all right frankie frankie where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
ohio ohio what city cleveland
cleveland uh and how long you been in la
um or california california
20 years la
about eight months were you married no
never married no kids no kids no kids
and what do you do for a living i
managed restaurants and i did
construction
you like to come down here to skid row
and pick up some of the ladies sometimes
yeah i do come down from santa monica
and um that's pretty much a place come
down
it's inexpensive and if i want to drink
and
maybe pick up some drugs mainly for the
ladies i don't really do drugs anymore
but
i have in the past and you like to drink
yes i'm an alcoholic tell me about your
childhood
you had a good childhood
no what kind of stuff went on
well the only good thing i can say about
my childhood
is i wasn't ever abused
but my mom died when i was six
she was 36 years old
and my dad my dad died at 46
and i was 12.
so i pretty much raised myself and then
i lived with a sister who's
21. she tried to raise me
i went to college for a couple years i
held down some good jobs
but as far as childhood yeah it wasn't
good
no abuse no beatings i've seen much
worse or something like that i just had
parents
who died too early no that's tragic yeah
twice yeah and do you feel like that has
impacted your life oh yeah
to this day yep in what ways do you
think
i have i had seven older brothers and
sisters
two sisters are dead
thank you
two brothers died
everywhere before they were 50.
so i just thought i was destined to die
so i lived my life kind of recklessly
actually i've had good jobs
nice places to live good cars
then sometimes the wheels fall off then
i reserve resort to my uh
bad self which is usually drinking
yeah drinking mainly
thank you for sharing that yeah
that's terrible yeah i've done a lot of
drugs in the past but
not not in the last couple years did you
go to college
yes i did i graduated from high school
in massachusetts and
i got accepted to harvard and i actually
went through harvard
unfortunately it was in the back of a
police car
but then after i got out then i actually
went to college in
umass amherst and i was doing really
well
studying uh broadcast communication i
was a radio dj we had our own station
out there it only broadcasted to like
half the campus
um i'm trying to think of what my dj
name was but anyway
that escapes me but then i came out here
for a two-month vacation
visit my brother up in santa cruz fell
in love with the girl
and unfortunately didn't go back
finished college
and this was in the 80s and back then
you didn't think you really needed
college
if i have my advice or anybody get an
education get a trade stay in school
you won't end up a fool
so you come down here to visit ladies
sometimes right yeah
and how's that go for you you know i've
heard all kinds of stories i've heard
stories of girls robbing the guys i've
heard stories of guys
getting rough with the girls or robbing
them all kinds of stuff
well what i usually look for is i can
usually
tell in her face or interactions
and i'm pretty careful and i've actually
met a couple girls in a bar
or in a park and they kind of turned me
onto some place
safe so when i come down here there's
only maybe
two or three girls that i look for if i
don't see them then then i leave
these are your regulars yep can you
trust them
oh yeah yeah and usually
like i said if i get drugs i give them
to them because i don't do drugs anymore
so
but um you know it's all a barter system
everything is for sale down here right
so you guys will go to the car you go to
a hotel where do you guys go
well i'm from santa monica i used to
drive down here
unfortunately i had my car repossessed i
still do have a place in santa monica
and i when i come down here i you know i
take the train and the bus down here
and i usually come down here like once a
week and i see some people down here
and it's a little bit easier to access
services down here
yeah easy to get around yeah
do you ever feel like you would prefer a
committed relationship a marriage
something like that too old for that too
old for that
yeah and you like the freedom and
variety that this provides
yep well because
i used to have you know at all a nice
place a nice job
but it was called responsibility
and you know now i don't have anything i
don't have any responsibility
not saying that's good i don't like
living on the street
but at the same time
i i don't have the problem with
an employer showing up for a job
a girlfriend and
i can do what i like to do which is
drink
and usually get drunk before you pick up
the girls
always yeah yeah and i always got to
check to make sure they're not a guy
so oh has that happened before oh yeah
yeah
you can usually tell by the adam's apple
but then sometimes
you know there's some that look
pretty much like a woman so
what's the most and least you've paid
for a girl out here
oh i paid like a six pack of beer and
probably the most when i had money two
hundred dollars but that was an error
i was in vegas different neighborhood
yeah
yeah
different different place different
lifestyle this is the least expensive
you'll find oh yeah that's why i come
down here oh i can go down to santa
monica but they're going to be 50 bucks
down there
i can come down here there's a couple i
know 10 bucks or i bring down some food
and you know a bottle of wine
you know they're mine for a couple hours
you know sometimes i can get some
vouchers for a hotel
and that's even better
so not too proud of what i do
but you know we have our baser instincts
and um
you know sometimes you gotta follow them
yeah there's many different ways of
looking at prostitution there are those
that say
you know it's no one's getting hurt it's
okay it's
both parties agree to it you'll see
people taking opposing sides on that
well it's a very complex topic yeah i
don't really want to get into it but
i think
if the woman's forced into it then then
it's wrong
if she does it on her own
and um i i don't think it's the old days
where you see
guys the pimps slapping around the girls
and dragging them
in and around and stuff like that
but unfortunately a lot of them
have drug problems
and you know and and
i don't really ask them about their
history but it probably
involves a lot of abuse
and um you know
they just need to get by they just need
to do what they need to do to get by
looking back at your lives and the
tragedies that you had to
go through you've had jobs
you've survived nicely
what do you attribute that to what's
your view on
surviving
well i've always liked to work and i'd
like to keep busy
and that keeps you on track yeah despite
the alcohol and
yeah and if i got money and nothing to
do then i go drink
but if i got a job i'll go work all day
and then i'll get off work and drink and
then
go to work the next day it did always
help that i've always worked in
bars and restaurants so
it was acceptable for me to be around
alcohol
and as a bartender you would actually
have to taste the drinks
so have you ever had a girlfriend
oh many a long-term girlfriend
and those relationships were were
successful they were good yeah
you know maybe it was my upbringing but
i never really had wanted to have kids
and i've actually had three eight-year
relationships with women
and they were great they were beautiful
women i was lucky to be with them
but kind of after like the sixth seventh
year
they started saying well when are we
gonna get married when are we gonna get
married
and usually after like eight years i
don't know what it is he ate
eight year rich or whatever you know it
was just
i didn't want to hold him back they want
to have kids i didn't want to
so there's some beautiful women
all right frankie well thank you so much
for talking with me okay
good luck with the rest of your life
thank you thanks
you